so eight on your Wednesday morning
Neighbors in the Mission Hills area of
Henderson are meeting tonight with city
planners about a new road that the city
wants to run right through their
Community City says it will help with
traffic folks who live there Say it'll
disturb their peaceful community our
Candace Charles newest member of the
good day team joining us in The Newsroom
with more on the debate sounds like
people are getting upset on their
Candace yeah they really are they have a
lot to say about it hey good morning to
you good morning folks well the road
sits along College Drive the states
proposing to extend Paradise Hills Drive
to give an additional walking and bike
path to College of Southern Nevada
students and alleviate traffic now
Henderson City Council Members briefly
discussed the plan last night but decide
to table a decision Mission Hills
residents tell me they're concerned that
the proposed Road would bring more
traffic to the rural community they tell
me that they are one of the last Las
Vegas communities where you can ride
horses freely without worrying about car
traffic while the city says the proposed
road that would connect access to the
freeway would bring moderate traffic
they tell me that they intend to include
trails and bike paths so residents can
continue to ride their horses and bikes
the proposed roads were suggested by the
city nearly 20 years ago but was taken
off the map after an uproar from the
Missions Hills Community then today
residents tell me they feel the same as
they did then and they intend to fight
for their quiet community
this time we're committed to bringing
the whole neighborhood to the city hall
and tell them once and for all that we
really don't want this road here we want
to preserve our way of life
[Music]
and that's just that the Nature has
changed drastically with Nevada State
College and the residential component
um the original concern was truck
traffic noise pollution
um we're not proposing any sort of
factory or any other type of land use
we're proposing a road alignment
adjacent to large Lots
Nazi tells me this plan is different
from the one presented 20 years ago as
you heard there that would include the
build of a Bagel Factory at the time and
that this would provide access to
freeway and college students now coming
up I'll tell you how the city says this
will help those students and why one
resident says this role concept is
dangerous for her family now that
meeting tonight is at City Hall at five
but no action will be taken instead the
city will heal from residents next it
will go to the Planning Commission in
September and then the city council we
of course keep you updated but for now
live in The Newsroom I'm Candace Charles
8 News Now